[Music]
my name is Dan Miller I am the founder
and CEO of Sephora Health we are a
primary care practice uniquely designed
for people of color I've had hundreds of
meetings from Fortune 100 companies down
to startups I'm often the only person of
color in the room trying to get folks to
understand the experience of black and
brown people and how they relate to
health care and the issues that are
impacting them it's increasingly
important for more representation not
just in senior leadership across Tech
and business but especially in
healthcare if we don't meet those
expectations then people don't get
access those things motivate me to
create more impacts professionally to
help more folks to think thoughtfully
about what representation really means
and why it matters as an entrepreneur I
don't have much time I needed to find a
way for me to
upskill myself but also learn in an
incredible environment to make sure that
I am building the best business and the
best culture
I was very confident in my skills to go
from zero to one but going from one to
to n was very new for me there are
incredible professors here and other
classmates that have thought about these
problems and challenges in depth and
there's a lot of research and support
that SCP and Stamper can offer
entrepreneurs to help them progress
throughout their careers it's been an
incredible experience to learn from
folks that have thought a lot about not
just growing business not just creating
Innovative environments but also leaving
a positive impact with this focus on
making the world a more positive place
and more Equitable place
[Music]